hey guys I'm just it is Wednesday to
find out what day of the week it is
every single day hit that subscribe
button also I do news first up Square
Enix is action RPG near automata is
selling really quite well the publisher
has revealed that the game has passed 1
million sales on ps4 and PC combined
incorporating both worldwide physical
shipments and digital sales
unfortunately squared didn't provide a
sales breakdown by platform but on the
upside the game has a free demo on ps4
that's not related to the previous point
but I thought you'd want to know next up
Pokemon go creator niantic Labs has
suspiciously cited research that
suggests you should play more Pokemon go
and less of other games career high
antic CEO John Hanke expressed concerns
about VR this week at the mixed reality
summit in London he said my thing about
VR is I'm afraid it can be too good in
the sense of being an experience that
people want to spend a huge amount of
time in I mean I already have concerns
about my kids playing too much Minecraft
and that's a wonderful game where human
beings and there's a lot of research out
there that shows where actually a lot
happier when we get exercise when we go
outside you know outside where you can
play more Pokemon go pankey has been
critical of via in the past calling it
isolating I'm not disagreeing that being
India is isolating but I find VR works
best as a group experience preferably
while one person is in VR playing a
horror game and you pretended to leave
the room only to scare the crap out of
them hanky added that augmented reality
games can encourage people to be more
active and in terms of positive health
benefits he said he thinks there's a lot
of good that can be done finally if
you've always thought that what call of
duty needed was to be adapted into a
Marvel style extended film universe
you're getting your wish Stacy sure and
Nick Van Dyke co-presidents of in-house
production team Activision Blizzard
studios told the Guardian that films
based on call of duty sub-brands are
already in the works and a number of
scripts have been written so it sounds
like they make movies the way they make
gay
I wonder if they'll have a three year 3
film studio production cycle she
explained we have plotted out many years
we put together this group of writers to
talk about where we were going there'll
be a film that feels more like black ops
of the story behind the story the modern
warfare series looks at what it's like
to fight a war with the eyes of the
world on you and there may be something
that is more of a hybrid van dyk added
that you can expect the same high-octane
action as the game series not a literal
adaptation according to the Guardian the
first of these films could arrive as
early as next year if that's still not
enough for you the studio is also
considering a TV series based on
historical conflicts active lizards
first foray into filmmaking came with 26
teams of Warcraft which earned 377
million at the box office but did not
earn critical success that is everything
I've got a few today do leave me your
thoughts and feelings on today's story
in that comment box ahead to game spot
for all our latest features including
those on persona 5 and I'll catch you
tomorrow